are we live
what's a live stream without asking
all right
we all know the drill you know the drill
if you can hear us tell us you know the
drill
20 seconds of us just wondering
alarmingly yes
no one's happy about it but here we are
all right people they oh no that wasn't
us i got it because i just saw a word it
wasn't even a
yes yes
we're live
we did it this
this is not planned at all like if you
watched our actual review during the
trailer i looked at them and i said i
think we should do a live stream
just because i was like there's just so
much here
uh to dissect here that i was just like
this
we could have done an hour-long reaction
and that's not the format for it no no
no no most people click off after the
reaction anyway except for you guys you
might come here yeah
and go back to that too because we react
very exuberantly yes we're about to do
here really sorry about having to remove
that music though you like we've dealt
with so like i kid you not we've had
videos demonetized over like three
seconds before and there have been times
where i'm like okay if i just make it
really low like one percent it might be
fine no not even one percent volume like
yeah cover that they will find us
jefferson airplane themselves will knock
on our door yes are they still alive if
they are they'll find us uh but thank
you guys so much for being in here so
last minute so impromptu didn't really
go i didn't even put this on twitter or
anything like that
um but hey samuel thank you for being
here for the first time ernesto remy
uh andrew justin tj rob arkley
okay here we go john turn up your mic is
what they're saying
and and do we all sound good but this is
so last minute just wanna you guys gotta
help us out with the stream which you
guys ask
that helps that with the questions and
the things you guys put in this stream
are what's going to really help dictate
the way this stream ultimately goes but
i'm seeing that uh there seems to be a
good amount of people here that don't
really not here in this stream
specifically but just there's a lot of
people who who aren't fans of this
trailer and you know honestly it wasn't
until like the fourth time
we watched it where i'm like i get it
because i mean especially if you look
back at the other three matrix trailers
the last two especially being very uh
there's a very specific look those films
have and
they also are accompanied by the music
of rob dugan
which makes a completely different vibe
and here this this has a very modern day
trailer vibe about it especially doing
the white rabbit thing i know it's it's
totally apt for
the matrix but you know but koi what are
we about to say i feel like it's
intentional to a level that we're gonna
feel very like blown away by the muted
green saturation maybe some samplings i
think we're going to go back to the
matrix that we know but this is clearly
to me another matrix a different version
of the software and you know there's a
shot in the trailer where he notices
everyone looking down at their phones
because in 99 we were using pay phones
and now we are literally plugged into
the matrix i'm concerned that in the
hour we do this live stream i'm going to
need to check my phone 15 times because
i have a problem that's the movie so if
it was the same color palette the same
tone i don't think it would be
appropriate i think we need to show a
new upgrade a new version a new reality
so i think that's it's going to alienate
people in the trailer but when they
experience the film they'll appreciate
the fact that they've done such a
jarring uh visual and auditory shift on
purpose true i think though
i think that um wait what was the last
point you just said uh intentional shift
on purpose auditory and visual uh that
we're gonna get a throwback moment that
we're plugged into the matrix now more
than ever so it needs to look different
i did a lot of things there greg which
thing you want
but then i mean play it back but then i
immediately lost my train of thought
when i was like oh i have a thought well
let me just wait for core to finish and
i lost my turn i thought
i messed up john go for it you you step
in there i mean what i liked about this
trailer is that it's different i would
have been more worried i think had it
looked a lot exactly like the visual and
sonic language of the original movies
for whatever reason i feel like yeah
with different iterations of the matrix
a different time the fact that you have
the characters all older like this
really appealed to me because it feels
like an evolution
of the matrix into the future and it got
me very like it didn't look like it was
presenting the plot i was expecting and
yet to me somehow it still feels like a
matrix movie is being pitched to me so
i'm really excited and i kind of loved
what they did here but i also your mic's
really quiet i don't wanna interrupt you
i just wanna make sure they got you i'm
trying to crank this thing
joe what the [ __ ] john
how about now is it working any better
now
john's mic is off the lights are
flashing now
no sound still
well here
all right well thanks koi uh yeah no
this is exactly kind of this i really
like this trailer because it's different
because it isn't the same visual
language and sound and everything as the
original movie i like that the colors
are so saturated i like that the
characters are older and it's you have
all these expectations and you know
they're not living the same lives as we
saw in the previous movie and yeah like
with different iterations of the program
the software the matrix itself and also
just an updated time now that we live in
i feel like it's totally appropriate and
yeah it's like if this had looked like
you know all the familiar stuff from the
matrix i would be a lot more worried
right now and would be more comparison
heavy versus just looking as to how this
branches out of the previous films well
i think okay i i think i i remember what
uh i was going to say now because of
what john was saying and my original mic
is fixed was that although it looks
different there's so many visuals here
and then on top of that too
um
yesterday i spent so many hours just
going through the teaser trailer footage
and what was fascinating to me
is that you know on that side where you
could click the red hill blue pill you
can see all this footage and there are
people who put together a compilation of
all the footage there and that
essentially i was like okay this is all
going to be in the official trailer and
a lot of it is not in the official it's
not in the trailer that debuted today
that shot that was going around where
neal has that pose look straight out
john wick the other part too we're like
he's reliving the moment where agent
smith and and the train fight in the
matrix one was doing that like multiple
arm punch thing none of the voiceover
there's a lot yeah there's so much in
those teasers that is actually not in
this official trailer at all so it's
kind of weird when you're like okay this
looks and feels different a little bit
more artsy
a little bit more poetic
yet
um they're doing so much visual homages
to the original trilogy
yes what i'm worried about is if the
current population will want something
as heady as the original matrix i think
there's a beautiful
they should they i i i want to yes
please and but i'm worried about we live
it we live in a society we live in a
world where things are more uh
manipulated emotionally like the the
swelling scores have to be so much more
like feel this than they were in the 90s
and there's going to be such a different
tone to this film i think intentionally
that i do worry about either comparison
why i think they changed the color
palette or the headiness how dense the
architect is how dense those concepts
are the fact that it looks like we got
satie back uh but a more you know grown
up version of her the fact that we've
got you know uh yaya abdulmatine maybe
he's an agent maybe he's young morpheus
maybe he's the son of morpheus there's
gonna be a lot of really heady concepts
that i don't know what modern audiences
are gonna do with that kind of film so
advertising it to appeal to everyone
versus appealing to like they know we're
already going to see it yeah like we've
already got tickets i'm there like
hopefully warner brothers hires me to do
press on it but i'm there no matter what
as soon as possible but it's it's a
matter of selling it to the people that
aren't there and people that are gonna
need to go back and rewatch the first
one uh we have a heart out here at uh 10
20 by the way uh we he has to leave and
i i have something to go to as well so
we're gonna start i'm gonna keep this
one a little bit tight but going through
the trailer again there's i actually do
have a theory about morpheus and we
gotta get to the super chats because we
have some that have come in here
um no need to put other people down
jaby's great and the jaby is actually
the first one who got me into the matrix
in the first place and rob zombie should
come back
you know how hard i had to resist
singing along
white white zombie also great yeah also
the human is apropos
what i'm thinking i actually
i think morpheus is strictly a program
residual self-image there is a moment
that was going around from the teaser
footage that looked very much like just
an android program within the matrix
so here's my theory i think
i think we would have heard of lawrence
fishburne's in this movie he said he
didn't get a call he said he didn't get
a call there's been no announcements
about it i don't get why they would shy
away from carrianne moss and they
wouldn't shy away from putting carrie
anne moss in the trailer and all that
but they wouldn't feature lawrence
fishburn i i don't get why they wouldn't
feature lawrence fisherman so i think in
the real world because you have neo who
looks really old
i think
because there's a shot here in the
trailer where he looks old and in the
teaser there's another shot where he
looks even older in the mirror
reflection so my theory is that this
takes place a while after matrix
revolutions i think this takes place
like like at least a few decades
and i don't know how long but sometime
there and that in the real world
i'm assuming morpheus is dead
and then yeah and that's why they have
dual mateen right
yeah i do think there's there's a
nefariousness to him i agree because
there's one shot here where he does look
like
uh like like he's dressed like an agent
in the hallway but i feel like that's
probably very early on in the movie
before he realizes what because this
whole thing seems to be about
resurrecting who these people are within
trinity neo and morpheus the program too
and i think the program will help him
along the way that's what i think there
are things within the law about how like
they can rebuild you
based on what residuals images and ideas
you left in the matrix itself so maybe
he is just like a solely
sort of cobbled together digital version
of morpheus or something like that also
that shot in the bay looked like the
lasers were actually building neo back
up like he had the scarred eyes yeah and
it was a little laser nipple actually in
one of those little freeze frames early
on yeah you see neo in the fluid with
his eyes burnt out and you see the
machines it looks like repairing some of
his wounds or whatever so there is that
too as i wonder if they're like
keeping him on extra super life support
because of the age thing which i think
is going to play into it but i also
think there's going to be a trinity
awakening we talked about in the
reaction a little bit but i noticed this
time in the trailer there's the long
handshake of do we know each other but
in one of the flashes there's the same
handshake with the same frame but a
little bit
well i think that's an activation well
the fact that she's like literally
diving off the rooftop waiting
i feel like she's going to have like the
powers of the one in here too yeah like
she is the tr she's the trinity you know
what if she can do three of her like
that visual looks like it sounds
but what are some of your guys's
theories put them in the chat below so
someone said more uh techno music and i
agree that soundtrack the first matrix
soundtrack is one of the best techno
soundtracks of that era oh yeah god is
it great boy omni media in the chat says
trinity and neo's bodies were in the
machine city too when he was still in
zion's or where he was still that's my
point that's why i was saying in our
trailer break during their discussion
that i feel like the machines probably
rev like preserve their bodies yeah
for some reason because i they i think
the machines still want to like jonathan
groff reads like a like a machine to me
he reads like yeah not the not an
architect specifically but one of their
like high up like i'm gonna explain the
matrix to you kind of guys but but the
fact the fact that they end on the
trailer with him i'm like he's got to be
the main villain of the film or yeah
they need a central villain yeah and i
feel like it's going to be him anyway
let's let's look at some of these super
chats really yeah it does look feel
different let's let's go i got one more
big thought i'm sorry can i interrupt
you yeah go for it uh i feel like in the
i mentioned at the top the times we're
living in and the heady concepts and
those things uh i wore this shirt for a
reason i am obsessed with this album i
think it's one of the better pieces of
art made this century and it posits that
we became gods once we invented the
internet because we made uh avatars we
made creations we live and i myself
quijandro live online quite a bit more
than the average person so i have
recently had many a crisis about where
at coijondro stops and where coijondro
begins because i spend more time here
with you digitally i spend more time in
these little squares than i actually do
in a world not in these little squares
so if you spend more time digitally than
analog which one is the actual more true
self
i think this film will ask the question
if we are plugged into the matrix
willingly the machines have won because
we've chosen this reality we've chosen
to put ourselves in a world where the
gods are of their own creation we have
created these avatars of ourself what is
the matrix if we're doing it to
ourselves that's what i hope it asks
because that's a great question i think
so
more so than now than ever i feel like
people would be conflicted to leave the
matrix because i'm in the matrix and i
want to eat the steak and i also like
live digitally and i don't know if at
koi jondo is more real or this corporal
body that's dying and simulation theory
is a lot more popular in this day can
people hear you john yes they've they
they very much echoed that sentiment
okay yeah all right and yeah child just
can't be doing the album so good because
read the scripts listen to the album and
check out dissect on spotify and have
yourself a trip i hope they give us an
animatrix again maybe another one that's
in between ps5 games carter love joining
the chat stop here
like do all of it
like enter the matrix was such a good
game oh dude that's that's the one kong
thanks for being here and people like
you koi hey thanks
subscribe to koi let's check out this
first super chat here fear and loathing
in general
i think neo is working
i think neo is working as an old
software program
programmer and this reboot is trying to
keep him in check because he helped the
machines reboot it i actually like that
theory a lot because
in the teasers you see him oh what is
the word there's in the teasers you see
him going into a coffee shop the same
one where he's like bumping into trinity
and um
it's something it this it it's some word
that sounds like computer uh oh god what
was it it was a play on the word latte
too
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah um
it's uh yeah
it'll come to me but yeah he i think i
think he is a programmer or a developer
in this movie going back to the thomas
anderson roots yeah and but he he
actually has succumbed to being just the
the guy who's except is playing more on
the depression side whereas in the first
movie he's like i feel like there's
something martha and he's a hacker i
don't think he's a hacker this time
around i think he is an employee
i feel like that's going to have
existential depression problems yeah and
i think it's going to tie into the color
palette thing we're talking
that's the name and it's like in green
damn dude thank you for pointing that
out uh so yeah i want that as a tattoo
immediately
is that going to be this movie's
simulacrum and simulation yeah is that
what this is going to be oh i'm
immediately so many tattoos i'm just
wondering how much more
on one it seems like it's probably gonna
be a lot more overt here
uh it would what everything is there's a
deus ex machina sign in the trailer
there's a deus ex yeah right behind him
he's exploding like yeah but i hope
that's not at its expense i hope that's
intentional i hope that there's i hope
this seventh matrix which we assume it
is is very literal and then we also have
a mind blow and that's what i was gonna
say is if you look at just the literal
translation of that as god has left the
machine you know so uh that's a perfect
literal instead of like a filmmaking
tour also the white rabbit song is
literally about the white rabbit the
pills make you big and small like they
picked very literal metaphors here i
hope there's more than that he's not a
hacker he's a hacker david mckay
uh glad you're here for this love your
live shows thank you everyday non-expert
and you're an expert in kindness and
generosity
all right
dakota jones one virus effect hey dakota
thank you buddy shouts out hey guys glad
i get to contribute to this stream my
thoughts after seeing this is wondering
where it'll go uh where it'll be going
if smith died right so who's the villain
i have a theory about that because i
believe hugo weaving was asked to be in
it but he couldn't do it yeah he had so
i think there's going to be
what if it's jonathan groth
who is like a smith who is like i don't
know that's a little farfetched
i mean
maybe he's the next step up i mean if
you think about it so much of this
usually playing on the first matrix and
you remember that interrogation scene
but with the mouth oh yeah
how could you forget the teaser and the
teaser with the mouth that yeah that's a
yes and that was groth who did it so
maybe that is agents maybe that is a
smith what if that's a mislead and he's
actually on our side because we assume
because of his roboticness he's a badass
that's true there's got to be a change
also we saw that shot in uh and recently
our rewatch that they're doing that that
mirror down the throat shot is in a shot
split with the missile going through
yeah
so uh near the end of the trailer
there's a missile that somehow warps
through
reality which i think is going to
actually be a single shot i don't think
that's a mislead i think that missile is
able to go between matrix programs i
think we're going to see multiple
programs i think maybe when he missiles
like when he when he dodges bullets but
dodge is a missile i think maybe that
goes between different matrixes and at
one of the matrices they're studying him
with this
and like that causes us to go back to
the first matrix we like they're
analyzing old matrixes to upgrade their
new one i mean that's what they always
do right right that's what agent smith
talks about in the first place i think
we see it happening yeah i love this i
just love what this gets us talking
about well i'm like we gotta do a live
stream get into live streams you guys
tell me the matrix trilogies like we
i i knew i wanted koi for this video
when i was like when i found out koi's
also defender of the season die hard and
i'm like yeah i'm a pretty good defender
of the sequels too do a lot of mushrooms
watch all three movies change your life
jacob sanders yes procrastinate no need
to do school work most people end up
broke after school anyway yeah that's me
i'm here to inspire the youth
i just encourage druggies
this is a leaf says neo please should
have called this a matrix rebooted yeah
i think it would have been a perfectly
apt title and i think it would be fine
it would have worked on so many lip
layers
they should maybe they felt those two on
the nose place white rabbit yeah
yeah
but that's a dif that's the trailer
guy's choice
i don't know maybe all right think about
all the things we saw in the movie
like there's so many like that's true
there's a lot of meadows we gotta get
out of here
i have a feeling they're gonna pull a
force awakens with this where it's just
a soft remake of the original remake of
the original matrix like would you say
the same i think
to a certain extent
they will be doing it but i think the
commentary will be more deep than just a
rehash of the first one because lana
wachowski is returning you know i think
it's gonna be like star trek the first
jj star trek where it's gonna be a
prequel sequel reboot i think it's gonna
reinvent the first it's gonna be a
sequel to the third but it's also gonna
start the franchise over again yeah so i
think it's gonna be a solid prequel sql
reboot yeah absolutely um i would be
very surprised if it doesn't decide to
go deeper and ask more questions because
i don't think it if they're just
rehashing why would i don't think lana
wachowski would just return for that
they bring down pay phones
it's like it's cool
as cool as the action looks in here i
just love how the main takeaway isn't
really that for like the last thing we
talked about like we expect the action
to look cool yeah yeah that's a really
good point though like and that's what
i'm excited about this franchise is we
don't care about the stuff we know is
great we want the next level yes and i
got this shirt from uh patron and a
friend actually as well anissa oliva she
gave this shirt to me a long time ago
and i've been waiting for this trailer
to come out ever since to rock this
shirt can you give me more live chat
leaf says neo plus john wick plus johnny
silverhand crossover and i am here for
that
here for it
jason rager
throwing a rager the maravindian should
be social media i wonder if the mayor of
indian will be in this movie i mean we
need a pervy frenchman but the
merovingian wasn't isn't this is the
theory that the merovingian is a former
one is that what the theory is isn't
that a theory common theories i think
it's a common theory but i don't know
accurate yeah yeah i don't know i think
people said it but i don't think it
myself because i just don't see the
corruption of the one going to that
level so that would kind of rewrite the
concepts of the one to such a level
they'd have to have a new oracle to
explain it okay which might be sati
right true sure so i think she's gonna
be an oracle-esque character oh so many
times in the chat of city freeze one of
the earlier films of the trailer shows
dead eyeless neo being worked on by
sentinels so yeah i think my theory
might hold up that's what we're talking
about yeah they they revive all right
that's the jesus metaphor we've had
throughout the three films like we had a
lot of jesus in neo so that that would
play when the romans went inside the
tomb and worked on jesus
and then easter rebooted
mary strong trinity choice but i think
the mayoral vengeance should still be in
here oh you gotta bring back persephone
man rakesh hari says that that actor is
part of the cast so if that's oh is he
that's oh is he yeah i know that that's
exciting not in the trailer at all
though
jb bona fasio bonifacio morpheus side of
the matrix online video game so i think
that's canon i know the wachowskis were
involved in that game
and i i i don't enter the matrix as
canon there are and i wasn't sure
because there's a yeah it's like he dies
dies but i feel like there was a further
iteration of the games where it was
revealed that he didn't actually die
these games sound great but
but depending on who you talk to
morpheus is or has been dead recently
really yeah yeah so i don't know i mean
maybe i was thinking about that like
maybe because they called hugo weaving
but didn't call lawrence fishburn maybe
that is true
because from what i've heard they've
always wanted like you know the gaming
industry or the games to continue the
matrix basically well they i mean yeah
the video games and uh anime were a
great inspiration for the visual palette
and even the world building and comic
books like the steve gross like letter
like they did the storyboards like a
comic book and i really wouldn't want
her to be any other way no
like but full disclosure i never played
matrix online but i like watched videos
to understand what goes on in there yeah
but i played enter the matrix i beat
that from beginning to end
jada pinkett smith man um oh yeah and uh
jada pinkett smith some people are
speculating that it's uh her and morphe
niobe and morpheus is
offspring is is whoever is playing for
him
is that that kid yeah
but my curiosity is if we're gonna
address
all of the things reloaded and
revolutions posited but didn't prove
like there's so many theories like for
example the murmur of indian like where
it's like we have this idea like will
this answer questions or just ask more
to do the prequel sequel reboot thing oh
and somebody else uh rakesh is again
pointing out the the other agent i
believe who we see do the morph is is of
the original trilogy so that agent is
back
no nice okay cool
captain obvious
i'm surprised it's coming out this year
and not in 2022 and christmas at that
also the song choice was good it was a
bummer to lose the song but you know
yeah it's coming out on one two two two
two one it is a palindrome and neo is an
uh an anagram so they're playing with a
lot of fun beautiful metaphors oh really
yeah really one two two two two one put
that together palindrome
release date so it's uh [ __ ]
way to go
i've been very excited since i saw that
because they announced that like six
months ago and i was like oh
very excited wow
that's crazy okay cool once in a
lifetime release date i don't think we
are going to do a reaction to the movie
guys like oh like this the matrix means
to me
i mean like have we done like movie
reactions
that movie means too much to me to not
watch it in the theaters the first time
sorry this helped break it to everyone
here right now people got pissed at us
for doing that for the suicide squad and
they gotta live
some movies are worth every once in a
while you know that's the way it goes
some movies are worth the cinema
experience thank you guys for being
contributed to the super chats too yeah
we had to eliminate the music out of
there though after the copyright claim
because it was like look we've been up
since 4 30 in the morning or we're gonna
we're gonna make sure this is monetized
because
uh yeah like as obviously we had a lot
of thoughts and there was war put into
it but let's go into this all right
nerd's eye view do you guys think there
will be a plot twist where yaya is
playing the role as morphe that's what
you just asked oh yeah morpheus and iob
sun
i mean
no
i don't think so i think
i think yaya is and i think it's too
predictable
and i think because of what i've seen in
the teasers that he is just a program i
don't think he's real
i don't think that i don't i don't think
he's an actual physical human being he's
making a difference i think he could be
enhanced it would be actually a cool
thing because he would just essentially
be ai
but a good ai
yeah i think that would be pretty neat
like and how ironic would that be
for morpheus to have become an ai like
that would be a really cool ir and i
feel like the machines would love that
and it would be yeah and it would it
would be a great middle ground too of
just like well you know not all the the
machine
machinery is just evil it also plays on
the subconscious right so neo is taking
blue pills uh by doctor's orders which
we assume that neil patrick harris is a
program so a program telling him to to
subconsciously dilute himself right so
the red pill awakens you yeah i think
it'd be really beautiful if uh the
machines know
to have someone that he's comfortable
around subconsciously he would
subconsciously trust morpheus just like
he subconsciously recognizes trump so it
would make sense for the machines to go
like haha double bait and switch take a
red pill from us and go deeper into
another matrix and that's when i think
we go into a different program yeah i
think the red pill brings you into a
deeper level of the matrix they have
more control over true true makes sense
dashiell milner thank you for that
moment of silence thank you thank you
dasho incredible tom
uh cory you want to read that
i wonder if either neo and trinity
identify identity change because of the
matrix or did they become reincarnated
instead of resurrected the architect
said there has been other neos maybe
it's the same neo reincarnated through
time so that's what was confusing to me
yes oh we got streamlabs we gotta get to
as well thank you to everyone who's
contributed to our stream labs they take
way less fees than youtube so i
appreciate that um
but let me see uh
that was that's what was kind of making
the merovingian theory a little
confusing to me yeah because i'm like oh
wait do all the ni do they all look like
they all look like yeah
yeah but it seems like this this version
of the reboot is gonna be different in
the sense of how like revolutions ended
but it they had to reboot it to come to
peace because the matrix was gonna be
destroyed from the virus was that always
the point was the matrix always destined
to go down that path like when we see in
the rev when we see in revolutions when
the architect and oracle meet at the
sunrise
does is that how it always goes or was
that
it was because the way the oracle and
architect interacted with each other was
implying that like this is a different
ending than we normally get this is a
different outcome than we normally get
so um back to that question that we have
what was the question that we had reboot
versus resurrection
um
are they the same of the neos yeah and
the trinity's are they reincarnated or
are they i feel like on this version you
can make it like another neo and like
it's it's not the same path it's not the
same thing
it's obviously got to be different i
don't think all the neos are the same i
think this time around the the neo is
going to look like keanu reeves because
clearly the awakening of the one is
going down a completely different path
than before because as established in
matrix reloaded it's always the same
that what the architect does he you know
he they find the one and then they
destroy it and they recruit some people
from zion to rebuild you know and that's
clearly not what's going on this time
you know
so i think this is the first time where
the one is gonna where neo is uh you
know just the same face the same model
what if what if trinity becomes uh like
we joked about her getting powers
alongside keanu but what if in this
matrix they know how to subdue keanu
enough that the neo has to be someone
new and it's true what the [ __ ]
something that was like greg there's a
correct
someone totally
dragged out some people are like oh
that's not cool i don't know i kind of
like it
he's a very positive clone thank you
appreciate that very lovely clone there
uh so like what if she has to be because
they're able to subdue neo's path as the
one so true becomes the one
and what are then the the his dreams are
those just like random flashes of the
you know
trace elements of the previous
iterations of the one program yeah the
programming he once had jill and the
chat's right always got a question who
to trust
all right so let's go back to the over
here all right we got peter cunnington
that's a good name i want to see this
movie but i think it's going to bomb at
the box office especially the fact that
it's on hbo max now yeah that's what i
think it's going to bomb now
i saw this i think it's going to
underperform not because i think it's
going to be a bad movie i think it's
gonna our performance is gonna be on hbo
max do do we know for certain is it a
day and date because i saw some fine
print that says available on hbo max 31
days after theatrical release for 31
days
four four thirty
i got really excited and then i read it
again i was like it's always four thirty
one four thirty one then the exact same
thought for like ten seconds i was
really excited for i want this to bomb
damn it hbo uh yeah i mean it feels like
it's what's gonna happen but pandemic
jones what do you say here i know
nothing about the matrix because i have
seen none of them
you guys convinced me to watch them so
i'm just here to say what's up and much
love uh go keanu you got to watch them
maybe yeah i lost the matrix at least at
least the first one at least the first
one that is a
watershed if you want to watch the
fourth one you should watch all three
yeah but
you should at least watch the first one
absolutely it's the very least watershed
moment in cinema i also think it's an
actual life-changing film it it's so i
came out in 1999 and i would argue
that's one of the most influential
pieces of art that is shaped who i am as
a person like hard stop that art changed
my life it changed how i view the world
i think about it at least once a week
sometimes more often i think about it
every time i see a cat every time i see
a spoon every time i like often often i
think of this film it'll change you man
i i hope
this movie
i would love to be wrong it's just with
the trajectory of hbo max the fact that
this is r-rated
i'm just like i don't disagree i just
worry about cinema because of it
well thank you thank you pj i appreciate
that greg variant in the chat yep that's
right we're really good at our job
pandemic jones says we convinced him
further change your life pandemic jones
change it
reboot yourself flev dorin
just popping in to say hi currently
going home from work and i didn't even
know the trailer was out when i get home
and watch if you're still streaming i'll
give my two cents
this is not going to be a five-hour live
stream today i love that i skyped in
later i love that i called you guys
driving after doing another two shows
and they were still going these
champions you know what i'll say too
like with the with the actual um action
in the trailer the fourth time we
watched the trailer uh i was like
yeah wow the action does look unique
like that apparently speaking is so
interesting
i feel like that's like early that's act
it's gonna be act one yeah i think this
is really gonna blow some minds there's
gonna be action people aren't expecting
it's not gonna be yeah they they know
their stakes are this high yeah they and
they know that like that i think they're
aware of how revolutionary who's the
action choreographer on this actually
that's the one thing i haven't looked up
yeah i actually don't know that i know
that we got a cinematographer who has
worked with which houses before would
you know who sense8 people on this no
that makes sense and ninja assassins
sensei people
the two other writers i believe helped
write the sense8 finale and all that
that's fine they got different they got
a lot of different people uh in this
chat uh
but and not in the chat in the movie but
i don't know who actually is a
choreographer for this movie
did you and wu ping choreograph matrix
four that's what
this i mean if you i didn't know i
actually don't even know if you know
being still alive i'm gonna be honest it
was like super old yeah
either way um yeah i think that the
action here looks like we didn't see
much martial arts stuff going on yet i
think we have that
it's chad stahlski yeah no way
director chad
oh cool
confirmed we'll be working
choreographing fight scenes for the
matrix oh yeah that's what i like to
hear there you go that's what i like to
hear am i the only one that didn't think
that he looked like john wick i thought
he looked like keanu reeves with long
hair like my brain everyone's like john
and like everything i've seen and like i
know i guess i separate actors
differently but at no point was i like
oh this feels like john wick
the character doesn't come across like
john wick but i tell everybody saying
like john wick four i'm like i don't i
don't feel it i i get what the joke is
but i also like i hope people don't feel
that way it's because it's because his
look became defined it's recently biased
the long hair and the in the facial hair
that look became defined by john wick
like that keanu reeves look yeah i just
didn't hurt the film that the the new
kids today that don't know the matrix
yeah yeah
why is john wick in a computer yeah
exactly like what's going on he seems
very upset about these pills all right
daschle milner again with the moment of
silence thank you daschle uh draft the
filmmaker what is your thoughts on tom
tickvar being the composer instead of
don davis can we pull up uh uh tom tom
tick for directed uh
like ninja assassin and stuff
he's a director yeah he's a director as
well as a composer
and i think he did uh like they should
have released this on jesus's birthday
i think he did some other watch house
stuff challenge man the palindrome yeah
use that palindrome when you get it
oh yeah cloud atlas got a cool face he
did uh the composer for it i love the
music in cloud atlas yeah it's stunning
man because cloud atlas gets slept on
but that movie transitions by emotion
that movie has the most fascinating
transitions arguably of the last hundred
years nah that's too much
i haven't have you seen sunset i haven't
seen sense8 no uh i've seen some it's
it's good it's just it's not my pacing
okay so i liked uh cloud atlas to be
honest i like clouds
okay so he directed cloud atlas tom tick
for one of the directors there's like
three directors on cloud atlas
yeah sure yeah look it up watch watch me
be right
yeah
yeah the two of them and thomas yeah
yeah yeah i think cloud atlas has slept
down i think it's gonna age well like uh
like speed racer has speed racers speed
racer has really come back i think 10
years that's i i mean i think it doesn't
send a chance is jupiter ascending
though their films often even the even
the sequels yeah the sequels
have gotten better and a lot not
everyone's i'm not going to be you know
those people who were like no those were
still stuck but i think there's a lot
more people who have come around on
those sequels and if you think about
what cloud alex actually accomplishes is
it it's about like multi-generational
trauma in its own way and then you feel
that through the score which is
apparently what we're getting and you
transition between what seven different
story lines through the power of emotion
of music they can do that with the
matrix yeah it took a while for cloud
outlets to flow but man what it does
well like once it does it's great yeah
oh yeah love me some paddington well
that's the other thing about this whole
experience is like i do if there's one
thing i associate with the wachowskis in
any variety it's it's like
distinct choices that not everybody
loves but that are very distinct choices
me mom that's impressive that you could
watch the matrix trilogy in a damn i
might do that leading up to this yeah
nick
in reloaded the architect explains that
neo is the seventh one he's encountered
each previous neo chose to save zion i
thought he was the sixth yeah i thought
this was the seventh i thought this
would be the seventh one
correct us in the chat
uh uh he chose his yeah broke the loop
because he chose love yeah each previous
uh neo chose save zion over trinity he
broke the loop i wonder which one he is
now eighth ninth a hundredth same i
think it's just the very next one
yeah yeah yeah i mean because it seems
like he's lived
just a longer life yeah that aging
mirror shot makes me think it's the next
one and time has passed yeah yeah at
least twenty two i think it is i think
it is yeah it's gotta be at least twenty
two bucks he looks [ __ ] old yeah he
looks like fifty years old yeah also how
do you eat all this [ __ ] how do you age
in a bubble we don't know yes jaretay uh
the the wachowskis did direct paddington
they did it's incredible cloud
paddington wait watch out
they absolutely did not direct bags
oh man he's the real one
okay
um let's see marmalade and justice hey
sean mclaughlin hey sean super chat
to praise the super chat commitment on
your spider-man stream six hours of fan
devotion humblest channel going oh and
the trailer's dope i don't know about
the humblest
yeah we're pretty cocky we're so humble
right now let me tell you how my
arrogance raises theirs up
it's just the presentation you know
we're on camera we got to look humble
it's the characters we created
a couple of hours in real life i'm just
daniel day lewis
in that scene when he in and there will
be blood going why don't i own this
oh i don't that's just me all the time
why isn't this monetized why isn't this
monetized
why don't we get as many super chats as
john campion
yeah man we should be so lucky as to
have companion videos to shoot
for these things
oh yes yes yes thank you sean frank dx
what's
up guys i would love to see the twins
again in this movie the ghosts they're
fighting against the biggest
i love the twin posters and then here we
are the fight against morpheus is one of
the best choreography in cinema history
and it's yeah and it didn't like it flew
over my head at the time like i knew
they had that phasing power but i was
like oh they're supposed to be ghosts
yes i forgot there's a whole like ghosts
and vampires elements vampires yeah
the second two movies were like
everything in the matrix is about
blankety blank that i don't think they
ever really landed
i'm really curious if that happens in
this one i hope there are werewolves in
this one before author p gaming in the
chat is saying 12 21 the bible allegory
first kings chapter 22 verse 21 of the
bible then a spirit came forward stood
before the lord and said i will entice
him by what means ask the lord
it sounds like neo is going to be
tempted with some type of choice to have
to make again at the end
and i wonder what that choice might be
trinity or the matrix end the franchise
or keep it going for some more might be
trinity or the matrix because uh
isn't a big part of why neo is neo is
due to the love of trinidad yeah him
choosing trinity what if he doesn't this
time him choose whatever he has to
choose him or the matrix she chooses the
matrix
yeah she's like sorry a better dick yeah
i figured my own stuff out have you seen
yayan watchman yeah i have choices
in westworld there's way better
artificial intelligence sex out there
that's right anyway doing that comic
book shopping the week after yaya dick
on tv was a bold move for the comments
oh yeah oh just like yaya can i see it i
was just happy for them we briefly
talked we could do this episode naked
yeah dude the store is closed we got
not
recommend if you available want to learn
more about the matrix check them out
alice's or him out alice's adventures in
wonderland are told on a butcher from
oxford's folly bridge
um i forgot i thought
out of the word antelope or floxson is a
word i believe floxson is a prescription
for like depression and then antelope is
like some type of
deeper
[ __ ] thing that i don't remember
because he doesn't do i didn't see any
leaks from the matrix explained guy
uh you got to be careful like the the
leaks on here are uh
i i don't know
i'm i'm hurt someone said i want to look
at any leaks if they're not spiderman
yeah i only watch spiderman
uh okay nature be i got it and flocks
him with depression he said something
about i think so i think it's like an
act that's that is a riff on an actual
medication so that would tie into what
we assume his experience is in this
reality
yeah i wonder if there's gonna be some
type of commentary about like psychiatry
being [ __ ] up i mean it's a
scientology movie
tom cruise is the one we meet definitely
scientologists those are chosen yeah
undoubtedly
there might be a commentary on like
mental health being plugged into the
matrix being like beneficial or
detrimental like the first ones were but
now we live again that's my rant i mean
this struggle to deal with reality yeah
you know we're in that that's harder
than ever when everyone's like on their
phones and he looks up and there's
people on their phones above him in
another box yeah we're all in boxes
looking in little boxes and i think
that's more real than this it's gonna be
a very on the nose commentator yeah yeah
i think this one's gonna be way more on
the nose uh omni media yay
uh hey michael b oh i need to text you
back i'm so sorry uh i'll make sure it's
you back over this room i'm so sorry i
love you guys that's why you're super
chatted text me back i love you guys
that's it so glad to be talking about
this world again yes man i'm very so
much excited for it i assumed you'd
probably be a big matrix fan yeah and
you have this shock we talked about that
clip earlier called rissian hi guys i'm
excited for this movie as a french
i hope they will bring back french
elements like lambert wilson the daft
punk uh according to the chat yeah uh
the mayor of indian is gonna be back in
this movie yeah that's he's is on the
cast list so you know you'll get at
least a little bit of you know taste of
home zooming into more
number generated vaginas
vaginas yeah that's what this one's
really about i hope this movie the
opening credits just you know zoom out
of a big number code dick we are going
to uh we are going to buy at another mic
stand because before this is john and i
for all these but we're going to buy
another one that we can set up here so
that way people like coy can uh i'll be
right back yeah you can lean in yeah
exactly
the movie looks like if netflix made the
matrix i don't think so i don't agree
with that i don't hear that i don't
agree with that personally yeah it looks
different but i don't agree with that
not in a gosh talk about it in the chat
with everyone you know as long as you
don't personally insult people yeah but
i'm very curious
yes
curtis mason
uh this trailer looks amazing i was kind
of late to the matrix bandwagon but i am
so excited for this reboot and i hope
they capture the things that worked in
the first three films that avoid some of
the missteps from two and three
i i'm sure they hope that too
um
well yeah i mean i think
what needs i i think what goes wrong
with the matrix sequels here's my
opinion i think
the matrix one is the best
film out of them all it's got a great
plot great story beats great arcs
emotionally swelling
where the matrix reloaded is a better
matrix movie but not a better film and
do you hear what i mean by that like the
enhancement of the world the
philosophy the unplugged nature of the
writing and directing it's a better
matrix movie but it's not a better like
overall film i would say
i think matrix two and three if they've
done the original plan of having the
animatrix be in film like they wanted to
do a matrix prequel and a matrix sequel
they wanted three films and from what i
hear warner brothers was like yeah i can
do three films but they're sequels so
they split what was going to be one
movie that was the sequel into two films
and then they made the animatrix the
prequel and matrix is stunning yeah but
i think making the the second film too
kind of bloated everything and that
caused the film to feel waterlogged in a
way that i think could have been a
masterpiece that was a singular film i
think it could be a great three-hour
movie or
this movie is going to do what that
movie intended to do with pacing and
re-establishing and stuff i think this
will make two and three better i think
four is gonna enhance two and three i
heard multiple people say that two and
three work a lot better if you watch
them in one go and that's what i think
it was meant to be yes so this four
might give us that little tape
absolutely i mean i i think though that
this trailer is bringing it back a
little bit more to the matrix one and
especially with the way how you're
focusing on keanu reeves as just a
character in this world do it on a path
to rediscovery
so it does keep it more character
focused for your main protagonist
whereas
two and three are like
for a lot of just like talking heads of
philosophy which i love yeah i love but
i totally get that it's not like the
most emotionally engaging or a hero's
journey or something but i i in car
stuff but i love the world building it
does in the sense of like how much of a
mind [ __ ] it is by the time you get
to matrix reloaded where you're like
this is the sixth one what
they don't win this is terrible like
yeah like so i i love that um and they
were so mind-blowing as a kid yeah and
they hold up but like i remember just
not being able to hang with two and
three in theaters just like what is he
saying what is the architect what does
it mean yeah it's like it gets it gets a
little too bogged down and and how deep
it is yeah how deep it wants to be that
it misses like some basic emotional
storytelling yeah
and it's like but let's sprinkle some
cool action season here and then it's
really easy to argue like
some of these action scenes really
aren't necessary but that is no matter
how cool they are like to me that
introduced me to like kant and joseph
campbell and a lot of things that really
shape what movie making is the second
two but unfortunately while they were
talking about all that it just got
really like too much too much time i do
miss the green tint and i'm hoping they
go back to it towards the end of the
movie oh i think they i wanted to flow
into like the green tint again where
like as the reality of the red pill like
as i said i feel like the world it's i
feel like they're actually funny how the
movie equilibrium seemed to riff on the
matrix in terms of its style but i feel
like this movie's if you guys have seen
equilibrium people take these pills it's
actually a really cool action film
people take these pills to repress their
emotions
because because emotions destroy
humanity and so it the way how they're
like doing this over abundance of blue
pills in here and like red pills it
seems like
you know blue pills will suppress you
red pills awaken you just like the first
movie but now over abundance with
humanity it seems like that a lot of
people are probably stuck on the blue
pills here you know
i
hope that we see the green wash but i
hope we get another third visual i feel
like the hyper saturation you kept
mentioning is a reality i hope we see
the green reality but i hope there is
another iteration of software
yeah i'd be down with that
rakesh hari thank you for the moment of
silence
i appreciate that all right guys here
for 20 more minutes
let's go here the mtv movie awards is
still cool oh the willful
is the architect so good that is still
like yes yes go for architect absolutely
that was peak mtv skits it was long
after they stopped playing music but it
was good for their skits you can show uh
moist slops comment okay okay
we'll just have a moment of silence for
people to to soak that in yes we're
talking it up because they need it they
need the help from us they do it's true
feeling that slob those wachowskis man
a lot of people keep saying this movie
looks bad and i keep not seeing why
i feel like yeah it easily looks a bit
different but i don't think it's i i
welcome you to be in the chat here and
and say
why you think it's bad or why you think
it's going to be bad like i i don't mind
you saying that as someone who has
who liked two sequels and a lot of
people did it
i don't mind it survived
reload revolutions like
we can handle you coming in here and
being like you know uh mean about about
or like critical of it but you know just
back it up
should we keep these on or should we
should we kill them now uh no you keep
it on right now i mean let's let's see
here just a couple more minutes all
right make sure koi gets out of here on
time i mean this time
i mean a lot of people i've seen a lot
of people who really don't like the
movie i mean i know a lot of people like
disliked our trailer reaction because we
cut out the music but
yeah i don't know how many of those
dislikes are towards us or
yeah it's probably probably half and
half
go like it please we worked very hard
very early in the morning
um yes
all right rakesh hari let me get that
super chat back up on the screen here
you can't win with uh made with a
sequel this late i think it's so hard
until it's already out and people have
decided on themselves if it looks like a
rehash it's all that's what it's going
to be called it's just a rehash matrix
rehash yeah but
if it looks like uh completely different
they're like oh it doesn't feel at all
what i remember yeah people are saying
like midlife crisis and stuff and i'm
like well people do age yeah well and i
i don't know i i i kind of like that
tone it's a tricky prospect sometimes
when so much time has passed but i feel
like it can also re lead to some great
movie magic when you use the passage of
time and work it into what you're doing
yeah do the no way home leak from cosmic
wonder
you know
let us just have
two hours of not talking about
spider-man just two just a couple hours
that's all we want
shout out to curtis mason i didn't
realize that was the last super chat
that guy's awesome there's enough people
who get really mad at us for recovering
soccer and as much as we do
let us hone in
we just have another video
all right let's go back here rakesh hari
guys the matrix usually has a green hue
at the end of revolutions the oracle and
sati are in a hyper saturated machine
world neo in machine world now
um let's see here
very end of revolution i don't know if
he's in the machine world i think he's
in a new matrix i think that the green
is gone on purpose like we were just
talking about but i do i think he's in a
different program i think the software
has updated and this world is saturated
like it's i do think it's not machine
world i think it's a new program
somebody's earlier in the live chat so
they went from grunge to apple store and
i feel like that's actually kind of a
good comparison because i feel like the
more they update the matrix the more
they probably like think back like green
used to be and i even think of like you
know like remember when they rebooted
johnny quest with all the cgi and stuff
like green used to be a very future e
color i feel like just aesthetically and
now i feel like we've shifted to a lot
of sleek whites and blues and things
like that so maybe they're going for
that aesthetic in this
boot
i feel like some of the daylight stuff
especially the ones we're looking at the
sunlight seem to suggest enlightenment
well it's so warm like the the light is
the sunlight is so rich and orangey and
and warm like the color palette is so
warm like it's not even green
like the conversation about this is so
different than when we talk about like
spiderman or something we're talking
about like
philosophical quandaries and like
religious overtones and the warmth of
the sun how did the thoughts of plato
factor into that i watched and i was
watching the trail it's like i love this
i love the whole thing where he's like
looking through his fingers
mephisto will be the architect morpheus
mephisto coincidence i think not
uh but i do more
morphisto uh the sun is a factor in the
first matrix they talk about like the
sun burning out caused all this so i
think that moment is very important
blade runner yeah later on 24 9 is
[ __ ] awesome mr holdbrook
was that saute in the trailer in the
scene with alice in wonderland book i
think so you thought that was sati
indian girl from 20 years younger 20
years older i think it's a little girl
growed up oh really that's what i keep
saying sati you didn't really that's i
was referencing literally a shot in the
trailer i think that's something
i talk a lot it's what's on me i just go
no i think you know
we catch every few words of yours
i need close captioning in life and i'm
sorry again at coijondra where does he
end uh yeah i think sati is the one with
the book okay i think she's trying to
bring morpheus i mean neo back in the
matrix i think she's going to play the
morpheus part because morpheus is the
subconscious yeah so i think the
morpheus we have in the trailer is the
subconscious use of machines trying to
hoodwink neo i think saati is the actual
new oracle stand-in trying to bring neo
into the world by soft reminding him who
he is through the alice and wonderland
metaphor gotcha maybe she's yeah just
stuck around and trained her after that
that's what i'm thinking i think that's
what's happening the arts of the oracles
i also think the scene in the trailer
with uh
morpheus r con concept of morpheus the
fight when he says you don't know me is
him realizing the betrayal of the
machines i think that moment is when he
realized that he's not morpheus that
he's a machine and then saathi's gonna
be the one that helps him about hmm
dude coy
i thought i thought that would be uh
bugs jessica hemwick i think she's the
one he follows to understand but he
needs to follow the white rabbit before
he can get the answers the journey is
the rabbit hole the actual destination
is not the rabbit hole the rabbit hole
is what you journey through to sati all
right i think all right also jessica
henwick
perfection she looks awesome good god
she looks awesome
all right and martial artist
extraordinaire
justin strow well that one like landing
jumping and her flip over the car yeah
like she made iron fist so awesome so
freaking good i don't say that yeah i'm
like every scene with her i wanted that
show so she kept it watching her
but will finn jones show up in the
matrix that's what i mean he's about to
be appropriating all sorts of decisions
oh boy i i
want that conversation to continue
justin striplin
hbo max
is one reason why people think the
matrix resurrections movie could bomb at
the box office and to me the other
reason is that it comes out a week after
spider-man away home that is true this
is a week after it's fun
i know i'm gonna be at the theaters for
all week like we're just gonna live
there everyone's gonna see spider-man at
least thrice
oh man that's good and then it's gonna
be hard to get remember end game how
hard it was to get tickets on opening
weekend so they're gonna people are
gonna be going next weekend and it's
gonna and it's closer to the christmas
time family where more families are
together
and let's face it more famous gonna go
watch spider-man
get the kids together for the matrix
yeah that's true oh yeah oh damn it's a
one it's a that is the release date of
spider-man 17th is it's five days later
that's even closer it's not even a full
weekend apart it's five days after
spider-man
ouch i mean i'm gonna see both but
we're the exceptions like we're the
weirdos that are like yeah i'll be there
i mean i would be more than i don't mind
doing my video of like i was wrong thank
god that would be a thank god moment for
me like look how successful it is i
would be very thrilled if it's
successful i might want to see the
matrix more than a way home
i mean my cinematic
heart i mean
i will be
but like how weird of a feeling is that
like if there was like a decision to be
made
oh boy they're two very different i'm
curious for two very different reasons
yeah my hype comes from two very
different places i don't think i've been
as excited for a superhero film as i am
for spider-man since uh like leading up
to infinity war but that was 10 years of
hype this is 22 years of hype so it's
not to disparage spider-man it's just
this is a philosophical cinematic
overture to what it means to be human
well the problem with uh
the problem with marvel
is that
they immediately make you get focused on
what's coming next so once spider-man no
way home is done well it's a series it's
what's next yeah whereas matrix is like
let's just talk about this yeah like
this
yeah right now none of these are like
we're not
bouncing off theories we're going like
what do we feel yeah and so i i just
wonder where i'll feel in december after
the year we've had i haven't seen the
injustice trailer yet i'm going to uh i
think we'll react to it though have you
played the game injustice i've not been
read the comics oh that's okay perfect
yeah i mean i'm story i've played both
games okay i've read tom taylor's book
but you've read the comics yeah we
should do a reaction quite fun yeah i
know one second i know the other side of
it and then they're making the dc
animated movie now yeah oh cool i'm
excited i think it'll be uh you can do a
compare and contrast of what the game is
versus what the uh i should play the
game again then
it's been a long time i played both
games um
let's keep going uh okay yeah we should
uh just stick to stickers in case
yeah you could do a job yeah
tom gotta wrap up in 13 minutes exactly
we got the sean mclaughlin in the chat
says the sky color's not the same not my
matrix
that's uh yeah that's the take of the
day i mean i do think that's intentional
but also i i respect this not my may not
no intentional decisions are in my
matrix keep your intentional decisions
out of my
fiction
all right guys we got 68 000 views on
the other mix nice
should we see how many dislikes we're
not going to hit 50k i'm going to say
115.
i'm going to say
150. okay
what at 115 150 dislikes dislikes yeah
200. all right john's saying 200
dislikes i'm saying 150 you're saying
115. and i'm gonna say uh how many views
we're at 69k
six and a half thousand likes
i'm going to say 3 000 likes geez
i know what happens when you got to
remove a song from a trailer i know
people get mad so six thousand one
fifteen three thousand one fifty what's
your up likes
up likes um one two seven thousand oh
okay 4.2 likes
120 dislikes koi you were closer
were you on the likes
seven thousand
i was closer on the line
your cynicism works for the darkness
and my optimism works for people aren't
so bad that's not too bad combined were
realistic yeah nice
all right incredible tom also that's how
i should so i stay positive guys
how many dislikes do we count
thank you to those who are understanding
for
how much we have you know man we've
yeah we've we've sacrificed far too many
reactions none of us slept for those
times
um
stephen owens incredible tom also
i think priyanka may be playing the
little girl that sarah was protecting
see incredible tom makes a great point
that's why i was like i don't think
that's
not
sati because i believe priyanka is cast
for this movie
and uh
and so priya and then nick jonas is
doing the the theme song for her that's
right
you guys rage against machine has been
replaced by nick jonas
the edgiest jonas
at the end it's him doing a cover of
rage it's the same song
oh man um and rob zombie he's covering
the original track uh yeah the
resurrection yeah
why don't more people like this that's
what we should have done with the
interaction why don't
um
so uh yeah i feel like that makes more
sense that you would get priyanka for
that yeah it's a bigger role yeah that's
a big actress i'm curious though it
looks so much like her i hope they do
terrible flashbacks in this just
awful flashlight
all right here we go uh let's see here
stephen owens thomas hopkins is cast so
i'm guessing she may be the new oracle
also are all agents road programs now
now that being the agent assimilated now
being that the agent assimilated the cop
but they did that from all the time in
the first one yeah i mean the whole
prologue like you see guys the matrix
were loaded they just stopped giving two
shits yeah on that freeway it's like
[ __ ] hack everyone
it's just the whole fight it's just like
screw it everyone's dead everyone's
everyone's heart
screw and then even in the matrix one
when they're running through the city
chasing after neo they're just like
bandages like bodies go through that dad
and go through the yeah just getting
reloaded they literally don't leave them
yeah there's hundreds of them
replicated yeah
they know they know how much we cling to
normalcy and we'll fill in the blanks if
we have to all right ken chun 24 loved
it and while wbdc films have had issues
wb's long
off returns to franchises have been
great mad max fury road blade runner
2049 my favorite films of the 2010s so
hyped
this is different than those guys
i agree with what he's saying though
like warner brothers tent poles that are
rejuvenating franchises are great space
jam 2 a new legacy oh [ __ ] that just
rubs it that much further well you know
what fun don't you had fun i'm happy i'm
happy at least that damn it you're
totally right i'm immediately i was so
on board kim chun and then i'm
immediately devastated his champ's not
the same
sam's not the same category as
thought-provoking philosophical sci-fi
action adventure
both are thank you very much
i can argue space jam is i mean it's a
sci-fi action adventure just is it
thought perfect actually one could argue
space jams closer to the matrix because
they were talking about what technology
does to ruin everything yeah
or blade runner and and because the
matrix exists within the server verse we
could see bugs but like granny lives in
the matrix apparently so maybe granny
will show up in this was a part of space
jam so it's all one big part of the
spaceship it's all one going back to
that joke about granny
john perez uh yeah i just thank you john
i just noticed when the swat guy shoots
at the screen the screen is showing neo
in the matrix movie be unplugged with
the liquid yep that was that missile
shot we were talking about that's why
that's when i think we change programs
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i i'm yes
very fascinating to know how they make
use of the first film in this film i
love that they're at least acknowledging
all these things
i think it's going to be a commentary on
pre-technology and post-technology i
i've got i've got this theory about like
us living in the last prehistoric times
so i think that's going to be a factor
because we we live in times that are
recorded intermittently currently that's
about to change in the next 10 or 15
years like we've we used to make jokes
about big brother we used to make jokes
about uh like look at worldstar like
worldstar changed cinema it changed life
because we started being our own cops we
started monitoring ourselves because the
world starts it was exciting yell world
star and film a fight people got
arrested but then we started doing [ __ ]
where we record everything i think the
matrix represents the end of the freedom
of not being watched and i think the
commentary on being watched is going to
be a huge factor here because the
internet because of everything we live
through we're the last generation to
know what it's like to have privacy
that's all about to change prehistoric
times these are the last times that
things are going to be subjective and
objective because the way we used to
look at things being written is how
we're going to look at things stopping
recording now that's great so we're
living in prehistoric times for the
future and i think the matrix might
address that
damn i think you're i think you're
probably right on the money about that
i think that's what that shot represents
i could be reading too much into it i
think you're i think you're probably
read further
i don't think you can read too much into
the matrix there's got to be a reason to
bring back the matrix exactly this isn't
just and everyone's saying it's cash
grabber midlife crisis thing like you
would not do that that's a [ __ ]
trailer
i feel like the wachowskis could live
off of the other matrixes if they needed
to so bad like i feel like like it
always could be a cash grab but i think
after so long you gotta have an idea
also keanu reeves wouldn't do a script
that's gonna tarnish the first three in
my opinion he's got a very selective eye
and uh i would say that yay abdul
mateen's career is so perfect that if
the script wasn't going to enhance his
already impressive resume it's a it's
way more dangerous for yaya who's on the
upswing to do something that's going to
tarnish you don't lightly play a
morpheus type so i don't imagine the
script is light so i i personally think
it's gonna be genius he's like the go-to
reboot guy he's insane man he's ever won
candy man yeah tricks yeah but also like
the uh the the chicago twelve
seven rebooted the trial of chicago he
just brought it back but no he just his
career is just perfect he's going to
play every role in the next one he's so
underrated in that movie too
uh sean mclaughlin big dick matrix
watch watchman matrix times three is
shorter than your spider-man stream you
know
it's close because the first matrix is
just a little over two hours i'd say
it's about the same length as the
spider-man structure about the same the
run time's pretty close thank you sean
that's amazing drew kaboom moment of
silence but in the live chat you did ask
who christina ricci is playing i think
that's an interesting question she is in
the cast of this movie
any any any takers or is she just a new
character i think she's barely in the
movie
there's just a friend of the wichowskis
she's just gonna hang out with
one scene and that's it
i
think
she's gonna play a version of
uh
someone that we met matrix two or three
i think she's gonna be like
what we think yaya is she's gonna be an
iob niobe that's definitely that's where
it is
gonna be i think she's gonna be somebody
important so i'm gonna go the other way
i hope that in this movie that lana gets
to do
uh more overt what more direct of what
they wanted to do with switch
i like switch being a transgender
character and having like different i
think now is the time to do it yeah like
uh it's capitalized all that wokeness uh
no who is this
we're not on that channel today that's a
voice
let me see
let me tell you something about the
original matrix movies okay
let me tell you what those are kind of
about all right we only made 94.6
million dollars in an everyday weekend
frankly to woke up
go broke get well
my point is that uh i think that now
would be a time to really uh use it as
an opportunity uh to actually do what
they wanted to do with switch and make
that more clear with the character like
might as well do it yeah and i think
alana wachowski you know is probably
qualified to do the commentary on it
yeah yeah conversations to have about
just absolutely
justin strip mrs vampire i'm gonna end
soon hey sarah
i'm thinking the machines must have
erased neo's memory from the matrix
revolutions when they had to kill agent
smith this is probably
uh why neo doesn't have any memory of
what happened machines must have racism
uh yeah i mean i feel like the question
is though why would they need him
right that's what i can't [ __ ] figure
out
why wouldn't reboot with him
why he's a problem we should bring it
back why not just eliminate them or can
the matrix not exist without them
um i assume that there's something that
he knows they need information on maybe
finding someone maybe trinity maybe
without him they can't access trinity i
think they use morpheus yaya to access
neo to get to something i mean i could
reply john oh okay we got we got we got
a little thing that we have to go to so
that's why i'm like
my mom's in the chat i was showing that
to you to be like we do gotta wrap up on
time
you'll see what i'm leaving to in like
two weeks we can't say
can't say where you're going but it's
gonna be cool wow now i want to know
whisper in my ear
all right so elemental c donations are
cool right
they are so cool
shouts out to you in australia uh josh
techgamer india girl in the trailer she
was in three as
are they exciting
dude go to john campion man i'm sure he
got more sleep than us he's he's firing
on all of us
we're about to end we've been since 4
30.
this is hour six of our day already yes
incredible tom you are incredible uh
interesting uh is that vampires exist in
the path of neo game which the
wachowskis were heavily involved in the
ending of the path of neo game was
supposedly uh was supposed to be the
alternate ending for the third film
interesting that would have been cool um
yeah i i well they do establish a matrix
reloaded like about werewolves and stuff
yeah and so and those dudes are ghosts
it would be cool if they've decided
let's also be underwater
yeah
there you go
all right mr 47 i hope there's another
virtual steak eating snack that is a
great delicious it looks so good thomas
anderson
i was just thinking about that i don't
even eat meat anymore but thinking about
that steak and like when i see joey
pants i think steak
left them
there's yeah no thomas anderson works at
a stake packing company
uh nerd's eye view
one more question do you guys think we
will get a director's cut of this film
just in case if wb cuts most of the film
um
that's an excellent question i mean i
don't imagine jumping in the lights
i also i feel like what's gonna make it
to the theater is gonna be their vision
or you know as much as it can be i mean
maybe i don't know this is going to give
me some hate from a very specific
audience but i think that the warner
brothers overall you're looking at comic
book films very specifically but warner
brothers has made some of the best
movies so i think it's really really
hard right now with people being so
critical in warner brothers which i get
the animosity towards certain properties
but warner brothers is responsible for
harry potter
water brothers is a very good studio so
it's really hard when people are like
but that corner this isn't in that
corner i think we're gonna have a good
film and i think warner brothers gets a
lot of undo crap
maybe goodbye audience it's been a
pleasure yeah unsubscribe
that i can join my page today it's like
this guy yeah i'll subscribe from him
not not us yeah no they're great
[Laughter]
just my take
all right
last one yes last run rhino eat
y'all look up the end to the matrix
online i want that in this movie hoping
yaya is more main protagonist and neo
eventually as morpheus koi pond hashtag
koi pond hashtag
drugs
i am honored to be synonymous with
hashtag i'm honored to be on drugs
oh no i don't think it's gonna go down i
don't think it's going to be going down
that path no uh i get what you're saying
like neo eventually as the morpheus
roll not not he's playing morpheus like
the mentor yeah the guy that brings
people into the matrix i see what you're
saying i i could see it going down that
path but i don't know they alluded to a
lot with trinity that seems to be like
she's the lead she's the real one like
yeah yeah that's my thought
my my final theory is uh we all know
that mr william smith was originally
asked to be neo and did not take the
role
i think agent smith comes back and it's
will smith agent will smith that's the
villain that's the enemy that's the
movie that's why he has seventh matrix
that's why he gained a bunch of weight
yeah the pandemic that's how it's done
that's what we're gonna say we're going
to see agent will smith yeah there's a
there's a
neo walks down a hallway and all he
hears from the end is ha ha ha ha
and there's a matrix rap we get for the
first time we get a live matrix
just
got phlegm
in the stream labs bringing us full
circle
got home cool trailer excited to see the
characters back weirdly enough i'm more
taken aback by keanu's john wick look
than morpheus actor change
smiles and love to you flev
fairly odd asmr oh yes another lame
sequel to the film that kicked off the
woke era you all know the matrix is a
trans allegory right from the mouse of
the chowski sisters themselves enjoy we
will enjoy this
[ __ ] [ __ ] that is a good thing we
need more of that cinema don't be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] take it to another
channel there's plenty of [ __ ]
channels that are mad at all the [ __ ]
that's making people's lives better
there's a lot of good white movies you
can watch with white straight people
[ __ ] you go elsewhere
i feel like with the movie they were
being sarcastic
[Laughter]
if you were i'm sorry
with them with a film
with a film
[ __ ] it's only about to begin
film as rich as the matrix with as many
themes and things to unpack
i'm like why does the trans allegory get
on p i'm like there's so much allegory
there's so many allegories
why are many more possible meanings
triggering to you like man i'm just so
sad because it is a trans allegory but
it's not only a trans allegory there's a
bunch of stuff going on and it's rich
and that's why it's great and there is
trans allegory
and what an amazing way to tell a story
that's important through the matrix
yes supporting trans rights makes us
cooks
it's exact there's a one-to-one between
that and watching someone have sex with
your partner i think it's exactly like
that i think there is no better way to
end
this
animosity dude
that was um awesome i just i [ __ ] that
guy that was awesome that was that no
that was awesome i appreciate you saying
that
because the matrix is a trans allegory i
don't like any of it anymore i just
decided tagging out um yeah just my
whole mind has changed all of a sudden
and nothing i gleaned from it the first
time is relevant yeah actually those
lessons you learn those life lessons you
gotta get rid of them because they might
because that's what the wachowskis said
after revealing that it was a trans
allegory it's it's that dot dot dot and
all your other interpretations are wrong
and not applicable to they accepted you
i'm sorry about that i think you should
uh
i think this is what you got to make
your channel about now
just take on
[ __ ]
out the cameras
just angry and aggressively woke i'm
sweating with rage all right uh i mean
that's that's my two cents guys there's
no other better place to end it nope
nope this is it
this is the time i just would have loved
tissue they were actually sarcastic
and they're transgender and they've
actually supported us from the beginning
i was just listening to something the
other day about like the the red pills
are modeled after like a specific extra
uh
estradiol pill or something like that so
like yeah it's all over that
beautiful that they gave in 1999 in 1999
thank you in 1999 they gave people a
place to feel welcome and they did it in
an alternate culture of hackers and and
the goth clubs and and the world that is
just below the surface and now those
people get to be above the surface and
living very vocal public lives it's
beautiful they have these metaphors and
it's beautiful we don't live in that
backwards of a time anymore
[ __ ] that person yeah okay now i'm
actually
so [ __ ] that person subscribe
click that like
i mean now they're saying the guy in the
middle looks like leave it to beaver
i mean i'm way less aggressive about
that i mean
whatever you have a classic look boy you
got a classic and also all american i
just ranted for three minutes you had a
lot of time to come up with something
better than that bro like come on get
better at insults
you're about to keyboard too i mean why
isn't you you're a cowboy a keyboard
cowboy you're a nothing behind a [ __ ]
fake name be better why isn't your mom
in the chat she is
stephanie is in the chat yeah my mom oh
i missed you damn yeah no she's in here
rocking out all right dude your mom is
so supportive she's the best right guys
she watched your whole stream the whole
six hours i know she's such a sweetheart
so hot she's good people
yeah she turns uh 50 this year what's
his birthday in two weeks that's what
i'm talking about hey
i don't even now i'm more uncomfortable
than i was two minutes ago screaming
red
i want to know how you got that
backwards are like man coy is a king
ibrahim khan and yes i also cannot wait
for lebron james and bugs bunny to
appear in this movie bugs the character
is gonna pull off a mask and reveal that
it's bugs bunny and this has all been to
get neo to come help with the basketball
game
all right guys look
guys look
we gotta end this now thank you so much
for being here and stephanie is hot
stephanie's hot just when i thought we
were going to end it yes
how do our live streams always get this
off the rails we were like plato and the
thoughts of philosophy as pertaining to
later self the thoughts of
we've carried so much energy for this
i'm very grateful for it thank you just
a quick late in the game thank you to
alma powell for that sticker that you
sent last minute last super super moment
of the day right there
thank you alma thank you guys so much
for being here uh the matrix means more
to me than you realize and uh it means
all of us it's and so yeah anyway we got
eight more spider-man no way home videos
coming out over the next three days
keep a look out for all back on track
six hour livestream part two i know that
we gotta we gotta keep going
he's gotta fix the algorithm after
talking about something non-spider yeah
yeah you gotta battle that's gonna go
back that guy looks like the ally
version of billboard i am honored i love
bill bruce so much
so much that is perfect i had to end it
there i loved him but take care guys
thank you everyone who contributed our
super chats and stream labs thank you
everyone for just being here in the chat
with us yeah you guys rock except for
that one [ __ ] thank you guys
it's my birthday next week as a gift
follow me on instagram tik tok youtube
i'm really trying to get swipe up powers
i really want be on red carpets for my
own name instead of companies i work for
follow me it's my birthday if you
haven't followed coy if you're still in
the stream you haven't follow koi follow
him on instagram or youtube give him a
fall that's all he asked for it's all i
want and i'll see these guys very soon i
love being on this channel thank you
guys always like greg will you pay me to
come by and i said
no
i will get you 10 followers and i'm like
you know what for four hours of work in
this economy i'll be there greg in this
economy i'll be there
all right see you guys thank you all
john end it coy drop the mic
that drives sound people nuts
sound people hate that
much love everyone see you later